King Arthur legend of the sword become
the summer's season's first major flop
at the box office is film ages fourteen
point seven million dollars in its
opening weekend but the movie cost one
hundred and seventy five million dollars
to make how Hollywood is preparing for
what could be its biggest summer slump
yet the LA Times reports industry
insiders predict ticket sales will drop
five to ten percent from last year other
entertainment options are pulling away
the audience's from the movie theaters
Jeff Glor got a look at the science
behind an effort to enhance the
movie-going experience Jeff good morning
Gail good morning to you between small
screens streaming technology and short
attention spans it might be harder than
ever to get someone inside the average
movie theater which is why average is
going away the experience inside
theaters is changing as a new generation
pursues its version of movie magic there
you go you were just an airlock and wave
if it's an airlock deep inside a
16-story building in the heart of San
Francisco this is where the magic
happens oh yeah Wow lies what might be
the best place on the planet to watch a
movie
this is Dolby Atmos this brings together
the best of everything we have to offer
today the theater is wrapped in steel
boxed in by two sets of walls all
resting on a floating concrete floor our
goal is to provide them with a greater
palette
Kevin Yaman is the CEO of Dolby
Laboratories the space he showed us is
not open to the public
strictly a spot where the company can
test and show off everything we do
begins with a belief that storytelling
is a basic human need and engaging in
those stories as a basic human needs
Dolby Laboratories embedded a system
which suppresses the noise and Dolby was
founded in the 60s by Ray Dolby as an
audio company
became the industry standard in the 70s
and 80s catapulted in part by a once
little-known film today this cinema
technology blends both audio and visual
today we're doing for the eyes what
we've always done for the ears it means
using software to produce pure levels of
color as well as a focus on object based
sound we want to sound in the front or
we want to sound panning through the
speakers you can do all of that and it's
no longer just about the number of
speakers but it's also about not seeing
them when people have a reference point
for where the sound is coming from it
removes them from the illusion of it
being real what does he have on right
now so Evans wearing them this is an EEG
an electroencephalogram the research is
done in labs all over the company's
campus they see fire on TV and they
naturally just get hot right puppy Crum
is Dolby's chief scientist you're
measuring brain waves exactly you're
measuring skin reaction and heart rate
exactly is any one of those more telling
than others to figure out where to move
the technology next it always depends
you're watching a really adrenaline rush
car scene and there's this one salient
moment that
content creator is hoping that people
jump out of their seats well yeah we're
going to probably look at it Dominic's
skin response and you can't fool this
it's like a lie-detector test it
literally is a lie-detector test on that
one comes mental testing helps produce a
physical product the processors in this
projection room
that puts sound and picture in this
theater what used to be a light bulb in
a film projector or a digital projector
is now an array of laser light sources
that combine a whole bunch of like laser
pointers together to create light on the
screen still exciting for you to
acidities yeah both sound we spent a lot
of late nights here one person who's
taken a keen interest in this new
technology is a producer who needs no
introduction Jerry Bruckheimer has put
together movies
an TV shows
including on this network that are
memorable and highly profitable this is
where it all started yes this is a these
sound stages were the original pirates
pirates pirates he struck gold again
with Pirates of the Caribbean the fifth
installment of the series comes out this
month available in you guessed it dolby
cinema
is that the goal to get something to be
as realistic as possible that's what you
want you want the audience to believe it
feel it you know they're seeing it this
Bruckheimer is a firm believer that the
experience inside a movie theater can be
transformative and given the right
combination of story and science one
that isn't going anywhere
and you think the moviegoers will spend
more for a ticket to see it to see a
better picture always but when you get
to 20 30 bucks a ticket it it gets
pricing it does but you know what you
have a kitchen in your home right but
you still go out to eat there are about
40,000 movie screens in the country just
71 are Dolby cinema right now of course
there aren't the only ones trying to up
the experience inside theaters this
venture was aimed largely at IMAX Regal
also has something called RPX more
competition better viewing I like
Jerry's analogy you have a kitchen in
your house cool right I don't want to go
out yeah he's right he's right about I
like going on but it's the big event you
want to go out there I like going Thank
You Jeff sure